after a tough game yesterday indeed it
is the sign of a true champion when you
bounce back right away dania yesterday
was definitely harsh uh the way you lost
what gave you the confidence to come
back and play against somebody like
jeffrey and take him down
yeah thanks i mean yesterday was a tough
game for sure but i i didn't get the
sense that i was blown off the board i
mean my alakin experiment didn't work
uh but you know realistically ray just
played a fantastic game you know i
didn't feel like i was blundering a lot
of stuff so in a weird way it actually
gave me a little bit of confidence like
okay i still remember how the pieces
move
i can still make a good move here and
there and i felt like the big problem
yesterday was the opening so my strategy
going into today was i wanted to make
sure that i got at the very least a
solid playable position i felt like my
calculation yesterday was good and i
managed to do that obviously it was a
very topsy-turvy game lots of
miscalculations and i got really
fortunate there in the middle game but
you know yesterday didn't hurt my
confidence too much you say you got you
got fortunate it seemed to us that when
you got the rook on the rooks on the on
the f file and you got the knight on c4
that it just seemed as though you were
pushing very much in that position yeah
so that's what i thought but if you go
to the moment after i took on d5 and
played knight dc4 right i completely
forgot that he has this knight takes c5
bishop c5 id and he's actually
one step away from mating me so when he
played knight e4 he's threatening knight
g3 and rook h6 and i i was terrified
because i had completely missed this
idea he also has this crazy move knight
g4
um queen takes g4 rook g6
and um
and then of rock g5 i don't know if yes
oh yes you're showing the line okay i
can look here rogue g5 and then h5
crazy line i can't take because of mate
so queen g3
h4
queen g4 aeh3
oh my yeah and if i play queen takes h3
trying to go to h7 it doesn't do
anything or takes g5 quinn h7 so i'm
sure i have some defense there but i
wasn't seeing it uh but then jeffrey
played knight e4 and i think i literally
have an only defense this rookout 4 b4
knight e3 idea
i think without it i'm just busted
because when he plays f5 which is a
really powerful move well i can't take
on f5 because of knight g3 i can't take
on poisson also because of knight g3 so
i had to find a way to get my knight to
e3 and that's where this idea of b4 came
to mind and all of a sudden i think
jeffrey underestimated how weak his king
was because when the position transforms
takes b4 knight e3
originally i thought i was slightly
worse g6
okay so a3 bishop b7 originally
after knight takes d5 queen takes d5 i
was just going to take twice on e4
and i thought at best it's equal but
then i was like wait a second i've got
the rooks doubled on the f5 what if i
preemptively
play queen f3 threatening bishop takes
e4 or cafe and all of a sudden he can't
coordinate in time
and i think he had to go knight c3 and
obviously the end game is
i think not too much better but it's
definitely winning chances only for one
side and what about rook c8 yeah so here
there is g4 i thought ah g4 which was
crazy but you would have played g4 that
was my question yeah yeah before and
of course i was terrified but i think
this works out for white okay so you got
this exchange
up position yeah how did you assess this
i thought that i have decent chances for
and i was very surprised at b5
because that lets me kind of get i mean
his idea was after rook c and king f7
i almost played rook d1 and here there's
a funny line knight e3 oh sorry
let me just get my that knight jumps all
across the world knight e3 rook d7
knight c4 and suddenly he's threatening
both knight b6 and the bishop and the
pawn
so i had to be very careful how i
maneuvered my rooks
but once the rooks got in there and he
got at the time pressure i thought that
i had good winning chances in
i felt like it was relatively smooth
i was expecting f4
rook b7 is important
and i think at this point black starts
black's chances are exhausted there's
one other really really cool line that i
just want to show that's okay so after
bishop you won obviously white's winning
i found this idea of getting the rook
behind the pawn rook f3 g5 h3
rook f2 rook c4
and here after rook a2 i was expecting
him to go knight d3
with the idea a4
rook e4 and the bishop has no good
squares and here maybe this is
uh this is flawed but i was thinking a5
and
there's a couple of options knight
txc1a6
bishop d4 i just go a7 and i'm winning
that rook end game because his pieces
are out of place
but the cooler line is rook takes c1
um and his idea is just to give the
bishop to the pawn and knight on three
versus rook and two is a drop but take
c191
a6
okay bishop d4
and now rookie two
attacking the knight knight d3
rook d2 is a skewer knight f2 check
and king g1 and amazingly knight d3
checking f1
and the last thing i'll say if he tries
instead of knight f2 to go night knight
c5 and win the pawn like knight b4 let's
say knight before
rook takes d4
knight a6 and the most important detail
of all i go rook d5 and he can't bring
his king up to the sixth because of rook
d6
so i was like shaking and calculating
and i was so happy when i when i
calculated this line
um at that point i was kind of hoping
you would go for it anyways i'm sure the
computer will laugh at me
some great calculations at least your
braces
brain's fresh and the brain's working uh
you haven't played in this championship
in how many years i think it's last time
was 26
2017. so
you got the wild card nod what were your
thoughts when you found out that you
were going to be able to play um i was
honored i mean i was totally shocked i
think i was just doing some spring
cleaning and i had to reread the email
like three times wait a second is this
the u.s championship i'm getting invited
to
obviously
i knew i was going to play even though
my brother's bachelor party was supposed
to be during this time
he very graciously moved that um
so i you know i thought this is a
one-of-a-kind opportunity and obviously
it's been a long time since i've played
a regular tournament much less something
like this so
i moderated my expectations coming and
i'm old now so you know i'm just uh here
to have some fun and
hopefully uh
you know bite bite some of these top
guys a little bit yeah i'm sure jeffrey
doesn't appreciate the idea i'm sure
he's here to have some fun well i'm a
jerk you know all right well uh kudos to
you congratulations on your brother and
his impending marriage as well uh great
job see you tomorrow thanks maurice
thanks for having me
have some fun have some more fun dad
yeah i will i will and how about those
predictions by